it's the doomsday system and this was a
project in 1986 developed by BBC with a
lot of input from BBC schools but it was
using brand-new technology to remember
the 900th anniversary of the Doomsday
Book this is a modern version of it and
what it was was an enormous catalogue of
everything that William the Conqueror
had conquered no
the original doomsday book you can still
read if you know the language
these sadly are beginning to fail after
barely 30 years this was a Philips laser
vision player when the coding was first
starting when the first development of
the doomsday day started they hadn't
even got this particular player ready by
the time they were testing it they got
the prototypes there are actually two
disks in all these a double-sided each
surface is an active surface the two
disks were called the the national disk
and the community disk they had
different sorts of content they aren't
digital discs so you can't actually say
they're a particular amount of of
megabytes or gigabytes it had actually
got trucks on it just like frames analog
frames in an old-fashioned TV across
this width there are 55,000 tracks which
is about half an hour's playing time
unfortunately this technology not as I
say not only the disk but the the
players are very hard to keep in order
we've been in touch with Felix and can't
find anybody who can help us to repair
them so we got a couple of players that
work fitfully and a few discs that are
just about readable so this is the 2011
remake of it using all the original data
that's been devised to work on a program
on this touch table but basically using
a PC with Windows underneath it that's
where we are now yet near Bletchley just
about here keep zooming in and
eventually you get the map as it was in
1986 got the modern maps on and you can
see the city is now full of housing
here's Bletchley here's what people
wrote about Bletchley at the time there
were pictures one of the lakes near
Bletchley children biking in the Milton
Keynes Bowl and here's Wells Mead school
the school that contributed this
information the BBC contacted schools
all over the country
and invited them to write little bits
about the area about special things
about their area
send in photographs and there was a
massive operation digitizing all of that
some of it was written on BBC micros the
schools are trying to get their students
to learn about using computers within
this this whole project but then that
all had to be moved into a standard form
plugged into what we would now call a
geographical information system so the
country was split into these areas about
three by four kilometers so when you did
this searching down to a particular area
you would then get these little stories
or descriptions of the area and pictures
as well of course it was only cameras in
those days they didn't have smartphones
or anything of that sort
and they would have been film cameras so
they would have sent in actual
photographs on on photographic paper and
every picture would have used one single
frame and they would all all have been
indexed so there were tens of thousands
of pictures all of which were indexed
and when the program was written they
had to have all that data so that when
you clicked on a particular area on the
map it came up with the right pictures
and not somewhere else this is just like
a 30 year old Street it's exactly like
that and there was indeed a walk
function within it where there were
certain towns and cities where they did
just like Street View and you could turn
four sideways and backwards onto your
direction of travel and look at what was
filmed at the tower this was not done by
the schools this was done by the BBC the
Domesday desk and all of this hardware
cost a great deal of money for schools
to buy very quickly the BBC realized
they got to produce some other titles
one of those titles was the Eco disc and
another was called volcanoes I was
involved in the Eco disc and it was
about the ecology of a field study
centre
that was in Slapton Lee Inn in South
Devon and this was much more like some
of the educational software BBC's
schools were producing at the time
that's the virtual walk where you could
walk around the lake but also if you can
see the dots that run across the middle
there was a walk in about why there was
a paddle across the middle of it as well
I was brought in to do the programming
of this it used a language called BCPL
and we used the same system and the same
user interface as the Domesday disk so
we talked about 40% of our code was was
parts of the the Domesday disco and then
we wrote all these additional exercises
that allowed students to investigate
these this field study centre the plants
the animals the fishes the birds etc and
then there was a module that did the
management of it and they had to work
out how to make the field study Center
survive and thrive over a prolonged
period of time
a lot of the good features with the BBC
micro were a result of a very
constructive dialogue between the BBC
and daikon it was it was a it was a
creative tension he wasn't always easy
we didn't like everything they they
wanted but they were